welcome to this video a new part of
opening disasters yeah this time I'm not
going to show you just one game or one
game fragment but but for ya four games
or four positions key positions it's
about not a specific move order or
opening but rather a motif that keeps
popping up I'm going to start with the
one game that is actually very well
known probably some of you have have
seen it it is a very famous loss by
former world champion anatoly karpov
let's see what happened in this game why
it was Larry Christensen one of the top
players of the United States form be on
phone I know probably two decade two
decades from the late 70s to the to the
19th Larry is still very good players
I'm also regularly playing on the ICC
but I don't match him a lot because he's
just a bullet addict so it's not playing
longer longer time control like Blitzen
please ok we have Queens Indian Defence
one of cup of trademark openings that he
has championed over the years and Larry
goes for a three at the petrossian
variation yeah it is some named after
them the world champion Tigran Petrosian
and it is a prophylactic move pretty
typical of the Trojans this Bishop
before once is often harassing wide so
he's preventing it in fact I think this
is not only a prophylactic move but
rather aggressive move because wide what
wide wants to do he wants to play you
for later and here after cap off has
provoked Queen to see to wipe gets an
e-form yeah for this tempo a three you
get a little bit of an increased control
of the center so you can actually go
with you form camp of took on d4 and now
plate 96 yeah quite interestingly we cut
one structure that is some rather
typical of the Sicilian actually it's
more like a Sicilian structure then
let's say typical d4 structure or it
also could arise from the English
opening where C and D porn I traded yeah
now why played the move Bishop f4 here
white actually has a choice it can play
this move Bishop e3 Bishop e2 yeah many
many possible moves here Karpov played
the move Knight to h5 this move is still
I'm totally okay i mean this this game
is from 1992 something in 1993 I'm sorry
something that I should add more than 20
years old but this is still a very
relevant line nowadays night h5
attacking the bishop and the bishop
retreated to e3 yeah the reason why
black plate night edge fibers that he
wants to fight for this diagonal and
ultimately for the e5 square wants to
control this diagonal and d5 square and
here cap of plate and the move Bishop to
d6 ok move that looks slightly unnatural
because it places the bishop ahead of
his pawn said something like Bishop e7
looks more normal but what black one
city wants to put the bishop on e5 and
actually get some pressure here so from
a strategic point of view this movers
are totally in line with black strategy
however if you look at this position and
maybe you don't know it it's possible of
course if you don't know it I have a
look at this in fact the game only
lasted exactly hit one more move then
kappa resigned yeah I will I will show
you the movement white white now play
the funny move Queen to d1 just back to
the one and it's a double attack
hmm there is absolutely no way to
protect both pieces so cap off reside
yeah this was one of the most shocking
losses ever by world champion probably
but it's the kind of thing that that
sometimes can really happen especially
if you consider that cap off at the time
had played this line quite often as
black and with good success um in those
other games that he had before this
encounter with Christensen he had played
the move Queen to be ate all the time
and then the next moves was almost
invariably Bishop to b6 in what cup of
did he simply confused the move order I
guess so he was sort of in his mind you
already had the green on be aid and he
just went Bishop d6 without probably
reflecting that much yeah and then it it
yea it hit him yeah with going to go
into the one what this example shows
however is that one thing should raise
our level of alertness all the time
unprotected pieces especially on the rim
of the board this night is on the edge
of the board and is unprotected so it is
vulnerable to attacks if it is attacked
it has to it has to react in a way just
to move or it has to be protected and
this kind of liability can can yeah can
prove very costly if there is some other
thing happening that is not really a
harmonious in your position so if you
decide to put some light on the edge of
the board especially it applies to night
then this kind of satellite piece is
always something that should make you
more alert to tactical ideas this is the
first example that I was they wanted to
show i'm going to show you one another
okay this is the the second example for
this
theme for this subject of this video
again keurig young Jeff Grandmaster from
Bulgaria against Jill Andrea French
international masters from 1984 let's
have a look it's a London system quiet
opening black reacts I think in a pretty
standard and good fashion if Ian cheto
says Queens Bishop and now he plays nie
Dage five yeah note it is night h5 again
this night is on the edge of the board
and it is unprotected Bishop g5 it's not
a bad move though I mean I just want to
point out them the similarities Bishop
g5 wide wants to not allow the trade of
his bishop against the night Bishop to
e7 and the bishop was traded so I think
what black did with night h5 phone was
pretty ok there's nothing wrong about it
still he has to take note this is
unprotected white now went a form an
interesting idea pushing the flank pawn
here to maybe create some weakness on
the queenside black played the move d6
and after a five he went 97 so he
completed now I'm not completed but even
got his night out into the game and it
looks pretty ok what what she has but
the only thing that still is a little
bit worrisome it's the night on age 5
now a 6 was played the bishop is
attacked on b7 and Andre now played the
move Bishop to c6 yeah and again I'm
asking you have a look at this position
and try to find the best continuation
for white do i know that this some
particular a game example is not so well
known so probably it's nothing that
like in the cop of crusade cup of game
you might have seen before so take a bit
of time and try to find out what white
should do him okay I'm putting it
putting it on the board now yung if now
play it the move d5 and after d5 the
black player resigned the game uh-huh
yes that's a really funny move it is a
pawn sacrifice but what should like do
if it takes it with the pawn then why
place the move Knight d4 and this is a
double attack here this Bishop 16 and
the night on age 5 they are both hanging
so it's double check again the loose
piece on h5 hangs the bishop hangs very
nice and what about Bishop takes which
is probably the the more natural choice
yeah then why place the move c4 and this
is again really funny if black takes
Queen takes is a double attack again on
the rook and on the night Bishop c6 ok
we know the trick already a double
attack so quite comparable to the
Christians and cowboy game there was a
double attack striking because of this
loose piece on age 5 which is
unprotected what black really should
have done I mean here he could have
could have avoided immediate disaster
were playing Bishop see aid which is not
really great but at least it's not yet
allowing the double attack theme I could
have done something different here too
to avoid um yeah the biggest problems
here maybe just retreat this retreat
this piece and make sure that it's not a
tech I mean a 6 yeah it's kind of kind
of
uncomfortable for like maybe already but
you can go here and it's nothing
terrible happening but it's very
important to note that again putting the
night on the edge of the board in an
unprotected State it entails some risk
there and the technical liability of
your position is increasing so always be
very alert if you decide to put
something on the edge in an unprotected
State at term it is very dangerous
sometimes let's have a look at yet
another example yeah this is a game
between Bronco damiana which there's a
grandmaster I'm not totally sure if he
if he is from at the time of the game
was played it was Yugoslavia but it's
from 1987 I'm not sure if he is from
Croatia all so I think from Croatia I'm
not totally sure I'm sorry about that
and black is pretty look out very well
respected them play from Hungary top
bone theoretician is working with lots
of Hungarian top players on their
theoretical knowledge and understanding
yeah this is the game as mentioned of
1987 and again we have the London system
it's a quite funny but I found those
games totally independently that is two
times this relatively tedious opening
but have a look again the black player
is deciding to play with night h5
attacking this bishop on air for Bishop
g5 and Queen B 6 there to be honest I
mean lukács is a really really well
prepared player but I think he had an
off day when he selected this kind of
line I really don't like it at all he's
putting this night on the edge of the
board and he's getting a screen order
only I don't think that this is really a
great idea but um let's see what
happened here age 6 to attack the bishop
and 94 you know attacking the Queen yeah
Queen has to retreat when to c7
Bishop h1g five mm-hmm ok so what black
wants to do he wants to make some sense
of his night on h5 so if white now plays
Bishop g3 black is happy to trade off
this Bishop and get rid of his night and
this kind of position is probably okay
for black gown still nothing brilliant
but and note that he's still behind in
development but at least he's got the
two bishops and there is nothing
terrible happening to him immediately in
the game however after g5 damiana which
pray played a much stronger he played
Ned f25 aha again we have this attack on
this loose piece and what does yeah what
should blank do now if he takes on h4
white is simply taking the night
threatening checkmate here or almost
checkmate on f7 age for hangs and I mean
there is really no move that that black
can play in this position so a terrible
terrible state that he already is in
yeah he went back with the night not the
capture went back with the knight to f6
and now Bishop g3 gap intending all
kinds of discovered attacks by the night
d6 was played and Queen a three note
this has already this kind of
snowballing effect Black has lost much
lot of time with night h5 back Queen B 6
back to c7 and the snowballing effect
means that with with further development
of whites pieces he's attacking the the
weak spots end and lose spots in blacks
camp and even increases leading
development here the Queen comes out
with the tempo on the night it needs to
be protected there should be seven and
now wyd already had a decisive technical
strike which is no surprise as he is so
much better developed night takes g6
check yeah Bishop t6 green takes is very
easy
so black needs to take with the Queen
and after Bishop b5 the game was over
yeah black has absolutely no reply on a
king move I mean this is just losing the
Queen very simply this is losing the
queen or you can put some peace only
seven after which white would capture
with this covered attack and he's
threatening Wow a double check and
whatever winning winning basically all
pieces so a total disaster yeah this
kind of disaster is really due to the
fact that again there was a piece place
on the edge of the board the night on
age five which was unprotected and this
allowed this kind of idea like night f
to e5 where the Queen all of a sudden
attacks this loose piece and this led to
this kind of yes no boiling effect where
white is getting a bigger and bigger
leading development and ultimately got a
decisive attack on blacks King and an
unlucky positioned Queen so again be
careful with putting those pieces on the
edge of the board I'm going to show you
a fourth example actually from a
different opening no let's put the
starting position on the board to see
the whole thing this is a game on where
we see a white player that I don't know
Enver boresha playing against Allegro
monition Rome edition is a very
well-known respected Grandmaster and
where creative player if you want to
look at interesting creative check check
out chess look our check out room
additions games he's a very interesting
player this game is from 1972 in a
junior championships and sin awaits okay
this is actually the news of Indian and
then I count this game while I'm when I
was researching for my book so we have a
Reuben style and in fact we have the
hoop no variation at the
time a very popular line what's the due
to fishers use in the World Championship
match in fact this game was actually
played let me think about it this is
September 72 I'm not quite sure I think
the match was already over at the time
September 72 but okay it's not that
important we have a this typical
structure it's a very close position
castles castles and now it's why to move
the white player now has a wide choice
we have this close center and the most
popular way to play this now for white
it's not a very popular position but
there are a number of games normally
what widest doing here is moving the
night only three somewhere because he
ultimately probably wants to play efore
f4 f4 just like that for example let's
say 92 it's a possibility after which
black um again has a number of moves
let's say place quiet move h6 then white
is going to play something like f for
this is a typical idea white wants to
use the F pawn to attack the center
however if you look at a database like
the one I'm using what most people are
using of the mega database from
chessbase this is about 6 million games
in total there is also a number of games
about about 15 16 games or something
where white is playing the move Knight
to h4 ha night 2h fri we know the deal
those kind of nights on the edge of the
board can be tricky however in this
position it is not yeah I mean where
it's the tactic here why should this be
a a mistake is it a mistake as mentioned
there like 15 16 games in my database
and in fact there is this one game
between borussia and drama lee shin
hmm where the black player actually
found the refutation of the move 9h form
is a big big mistake but it is such a
hidden resource that lots of strong
players is black even some grandmasters
didn't find the refutation but Roman
ition actually was able to do it in one
of the earliest examples but it is
obviously not a well-known trap on i
mean it's not a trap yeah why this
basically in digging his own grave yeah
maybe you can try to find it I mean if
you know that there is a direct
technical solution to the whole thing
then the chance is much higher that you
see it but if you don't know that there
is a direct refutation of the move from
it is all the more difficult yeah black
here is winning with the movie form aha
so why is he winning yeah white can take
it this is a what happened in the game
of course let's check what happens if he
moves the bishop then we go g5 and this
night has no square it's just lost
attacked and lost so why took it Knight
takes Queen takes and now again the move
g5 and I think this is what makes the
whole thing and so difficult to find
this black you you are very often
reluctant to consider those kind of
weakening moves in front of your king
and here it is simply a concrete reason
for the move the night is attacked it
cannot go to f5 the squares double
protected so there's only 93 to save it
and after that black is playing Bishop
f5 and the queen is strapped in the
middle of the board the queen is
strapped g5 has taken away those two key
squares and Bishop f5 just detects the
Queen and it's gone so that means after
g5 this piece is lost because while you
want to save your queen and in the game
here the white player
went with not with this but with F form
and now after the move I mean there are
alternatives already but after f5 he
sacrificed his night there and now
played played with the piece down it
just took a couple of moves now for room
addition to to win the game he also has
this great great Bishop p extra bishop
yeah a fun really fun line that is
really hidden in the position so let let
us look at it again the whole reason
again is an offside piece that is
unprotected on the edge of the board in
all the cases some that we looked at
here it was the night on edge for but
there is basically the same thing
happening with the night on a five or a
four maybe h-file is more critical even
because a night on a four or a five
quite often is naturally protected by
the Queen yer if you imagine night on a
five very often it some sort of
protected by the Queen and on h4 it's
not happening on age five and blacks
case sometimes the problems with those
moves are really hidden like he I mean I
really think that this is difficult to
see as black especially because you
probably don't look for tactics in this
position you just think okay night h4
wants to play f4 maybe just don't a g6
trade this off whatever you have some
some difficult strategic considerations
to make here but in fact there is no
strategy you just win the peace we but
difficult to spot but okay these
examples and there is a ton more this
example show that this kind of motif
happens again and again its history
repeating itself with pieces on the edge
of the board that are unprotected the
author John nan quote and is really
applying loose pieces drop of LP dl it's
really the case if you have unprotected
pieces there is something bound to go
wrong so if you decide to play those
kind of moves that put pieces offside
really double check again
again if this is if there is something
bad possible happening to you ok I hope
you enjoyed this coverage of those four
game fragments those four quick games
that really show a danger that is then
that is around all the time please be
careful thanks for watching